I THANK YOU AND HE DEPARTS.
>> Bret: INTERESTING.
LET'S TALK MORE ABOUT THE
SESSIONS RETIREMENT, REALLY
FIRING WITH SOUTH CAROLINA
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN TREY
GOWDY WHO SITS ON THE JUDICIARY
AND INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEES AND
CHAIRS THE OVERSIGHT AND
GOVERNMENT REFORM COMMITTEE.
THANKS FOR BEING HERE.
YOUR THOUGHTS OF THIS NEWS.
>> IT WAS GOING TO HAPPEN, I
KNEW IT WAS GOING TO HAPPEN
AFTER THE ELECTION.
I DIDN'T THINK IT WOULD HAPPEN
BEFORE ALL THE VOTES HAD BEEN
COUNTED BUT HE'S BEEN A
PROVERBIAL DEAD MEN WALKING FOR
SEVERAL MONTHS NOW.
>> Bret: CHUCK SCHUMER HAD A
REAL PROBLEM WITH THE ACTING
ATTORNEY GENERAL, TAKE A LISTEN.
>> OUR PARAMOUNT VIEW IS THAT
ANY ATTORNEY GENERAL WHETHER
THIS ONE OR ANOTHER ONE SHOULD
NOT BE ABLE TO INTERFERE WITH
THE MUELLER INVESTIGATION IN ANY
WAY.
IF THEY SHOULDN'T BE ABLE TO END
MARKETS, LIMITED OR INTERFERE
WITH MUELLER GOING FORWARD AND
DOING WHAT HE THINKS IS THE
RIGHT THING.
THAT WILL HELP GUIDE US AS WE GO
THROUGH THIS PROCESS.
>> Bret: THEIR CONCERN IS THAT
MATT WHITAKER IS GOING TO DO
THAT.
>> EVERY PROSECUTOR HAS
JURISDICTIONAL BOUNDARIES.
I DON'T KNOW A SINGLE PROSECUTOR
THAT DOES NOT.
MUELLER'S JURISDICTIONAL
BOUNDARIES HAVE BEEN SET BY ROD
ROSENSTEIN AND THEY WERE AMENDED
IN THE MEMO THAT WE HAVE NOT
SEEN.
THERE HAS NEVER BEEN A
PROSECUTOR THAT HAD UNFETTERED
POWER TO GO INVESTIGATE WHATEVER
THE HECK HE OR SHE WANTED TO DO.
IF YOUR ESTATE PROSECUTOR YOU
CAN'T INVESTIGATE FEDERAL
CRIMES.
IF YOU'RE IN NEW YORK YOU CAN'T
INVESTIGATE THINGS IN IDAHO.
THE NOTION THAT WE ARE GOING TO
CREATE A SPECIAL COUNSEL THAT
HAS NO BOSS, NO JURISDICTIONAL
STRUCTURES AT ALL IS JUST
TYPICAL CHUCK SCHUMER AND I
THINK IT'S WHY SO FEW PEOPLE
TAKE THEM SERIOUSLY.
>> Bret: WHAT ABOUT ROD
ROSENSTEIN IN HIS ROLE HERE?
HE'S A DEPUTY IF THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL IS NOT THERE
THAT HE WOULD STEP IN AS ACTING.
>> THESE ARE INTERESTING TIMES
THAT WE ARE IN.
ROD ROSENSTEIN, I WAS READY TO
QUESTION HIM, I HAD 37 PAGES
WITH QUESTIONS FOR HIM, A COUPLE
WEEKS AGO.
HE WAS ALLEGED TO HAVE WANTED TO
VOTE THE 25TH AMENDMENT AND
QUESTION THE PRESIDENT'S FITNESS
FOR OFFICE, I'M NOT SURE THAT
WOULD'VE BEEN THE RIGHT PICK.
HE IS OVERSEEING THE SPEED PROBE
RIGHT NOW, I DON'T THINK
ANYTHING IS GOING TO HAPPEN TO
ROD UNTIL AFTER MUELLER FINISHES
IT HIS INVESTIGATION.
>> Bret: ROSENSTEIN HAD A
MEETING TODAY AT THE
WHITE HOUSE, DO YOU HAVE ANY
SENSE WHEN THE SPIRIT MOVES
FORWARD WITH ANYTHING?
DO YOU HAVE ANY TIMELINE >> FOR
WHATEVER SHORTCOMINGS PEOPLE
PERCEIVE THAT HE HAS, HE'S DONE
IT A GOOD JOB OF KEEPING HIS
BUSINESS PRIVATE.
I HAVE NOT SEEN A SINGLE PIECE
OF EVIDENCE THAT SUGGESTS
COLLUSION BETWEEN THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN IN RUSSIA.
NO ONE HAS INTERVIEWED MORE
WITNESSES AND I HAVE.
I THINK MUELLER IS GOING TO
ISSUE AN EXHAUSTIVE REPORT ON
WHAT RUSSIA DID WHICH SHOULD
UNIFY AMERICA AND THEN HE'S
GOING TO DISAPPOINT CNN AND ALL
MY DEMOCRAT FRIENDS BY SAYING
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE OF
COLLUSION.
THAT'S WHAT I THINK HE'S GOING
TO DO AND I THINK IT WILL HAPPEN
BEFORE THE END OF THE YEAR BUT I
DON'T KNOW THAT.
>> Bret: DO YOU THINK ACTING
ATTORNEY GENERAL WHITAKER COULD
EXPAND THE INVESTIGATION THE
OTHER WAY?
INTO LOOKING AT THE FBI, THE
EARLY PARTS OF THE INVESTIGATION
FROM INSIDE THE ADMINISTRATION?
>> HE COULD.
CHAIRMAN GOODLAD AND I WROTE A
LONG TIME AGO, WE WROTE
ATTORNEY GENERAL SESSIONS AND
SAID WE THINK THERE OUGHT TO BE
A SECOND SPECIAL COUNSEL.
I SAY THAT TO SOMEBODY WHO USED
TO WORK FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE AND WANTS TO SEE THAT
INSTITUTION RESTORED TO ITS
GREATNESS.
I THINK THERE OUGHT TO BE A
SECOND SPECIAL COUNSEL TO LOOK
AT THE ORIGINS OF THE RUSSIA
PROBE AND THE WAY THE FBI
CONDUCTED ITSELF.
CHAIRMAN GOODLAD AND I HAVE BEEN
INVESTIGATING TO THE EXTENT THAT
WE CAN WITHOUT A GRAND JURY OR
COMPULSORY PROCESS, WE'VE BEEN
LOOKING AT WHAT WE CAN AND I AM
DEEPLY TROUBLED ABOUT WHAT THE
DEPARTMENT AND THE BUREAU DID.
I THINK ANOTHER SPECIAL COUNSEL
IS WARRANTED AND I THOUGHT THAT
MONTHS AGO.
>> Bret: IS THERE MORE LIKELY
THAT IT HAPPENS WITH ACTING
ATTORNEY GENERAL WHITAKER THAN
NOT?
>> MY CHANCES WERE ZERO WITH
SESSIONS, NOT TO QUOTE THE MOVIE
"DUMB AND DUMBER," I GUESS IT'S
NOT WANTED A MILLION BUT IT'S
BETTER THAN IT WAS WITH SESSION
SESSIONS.
>> Bret: YOU'RE SAYING THERE'S
A CHANCE.
YOUR REACTION TO LOSING THE
HOUSE?
>> NOT SURPRISED, HISTORICAL
HEADWINDS, RETIREMENTS, IT'S
TOUGH TO WIN IN OFF YEARS.
WE PICKED UP SEATS IN THE
SENATE, I'M SORRY FOR SOME OF MY
FRIENDS THAT AREN'T COMING BACK.
MIA LOVE AND STEVIE RUSSELL AND
OTHERS, IT'S AN UNUSUAL LINE OF
WORK THAT WE HAVE CHOSEN AND THE
JURY HAS SPOKEN IN THE JURY IS
ALWAYS RIGHT.
>> Bret: WHAT ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT SAYING IF YOU DIDN'T
STAND WITH ME, TOO BAD.
TODAY AT THE NEWS CONFERENCE.
>> WE LOST THE SEAT IN
SOUTH CAROLINA, KATIE ARRINGTON
STOOD WITH THE PRESIDENT MUCH
MORE SO THAN MARK SANFORD.
REGRETTABLY, SHE DID NOT WIN.
I THINK HE HAD TREMENDOUS
SUCCESS IN THE SENATE SEAT THAT
HE INVOLVED HIMSELF WITH, THE
HOUSE, IT'S A DIFFERENT ENTITY.
IT'S TOUGH TO WIN IN OFF YEARS.
THE HISTORICAL HEADWINDS, THE
MONEY THAT POURED IN, THE
RETIREMENTS, I THINK KEVIN AND
PAUL KNEW THAT WE WERE IN
TROUBLE EVEN THOUGH THEY FOUGHT
LIKE THE DICKENS TO PREVENT IT.
I THINK IT WAS INEVITABLE.